back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
dude are miss Fields has Prince Fielder
has it Prince really yeah I hear if you
go to feel the dreams you get Kevin
Costner has it dude Metta World Peace
yeah he's got it he's gonna rant yeah
drivers have a KDF it only only rich
people yeah have it I'm cool this then I
mean you guys might be in trouble you're
a broke-ass Tripoli over here it's doing
fine
listen dude I've been eating the ass
since 85 I could [ __ ] system straight
o8 four times
well a lot of gay men I know a friend of
mine that is gay yeah called me and he
said hey uh about time you guys didn't
know what it's like to have to struggle
every day with a real disease you know
the point that's a good point because
they imagine having this every time you
go out to have a drink and somebody has
kovat in there but they don't tell you
yeah of course they don't you got
splotches on your face you know yeah you
got splotches low ready you know dude
and they said calamine lotion I've been
putting calamine all over my arms at
night not say not doing they say KY
beats it - dude lather yourself up dude
yeah
lather yourself up put on it they say
they say masturbation ups your immune
system really yeah well dude I heard
yeah but I definitely seems like I will
say this it seems like no one had like
has it like I haven't seen anybody with
it have you know honestly Brandi nah I'm
not lying not what you seem like you're
lying no I know Kevin Durant has it yeah
you read that somewhere
and he says he feels fine but here's the
thing they told Katie he's never felt
fine d if you read a lot of his post
he's always really been in his feelings
I feel are you right also for some of
these celebrities I feel like it's a PR
move have we started yes don't we love
Doug we've been ranting about 10 minutes
Eddie jump on in yeah try the water out
gofer swim yeah grab a Corona jump in
the water
how long do Corona changes their name
yeah their sales are down to something
crazy number I heard I heard one of
their briefs are you getting a 99-cent
store right in that like discount bin
yeah but I don't know if they sell glass
in there
that's the only thing since I've put it
into plastic bottles it would sell it if
you want me a good woman go to 99-cent
store you see some hot broke [ __ ]
yeah but also women that are smart they
think ahead
there are ahead of the curve good with
money yeah you meet a lot of hoes at
Whole Foods dude that's what they say
that's yeah hoe and hoe food that's true
oh yeah but not one of them though those
are high yeah organic yeah yeah you got
to get a woman off a farm I feel like
these days nah dude traffic courts a
great place to meet chicks he's got a
girlfriend now
mm-hmm I got an ex-girlfriend out but
maybe we might get back together I don't
know but I hope so yeah anything would
help but I heard miss Fields has it who
else here's another thing a where all
the [ __ ] women get in the disease
women are receptors I thought yeah so
few women getting it it is ridiculous
crying about it but again I don't trust
these celebs with these this PR stuff
Ron Paul just put out a video yesterday
calling I mean the name of the video is
the corona virus hoaxes Wow Ron Paul
saying it's a total did you see that
video I didn't see you Ron Paul it's his
YouTube channel is we got it up we got a
Ron Paul's a real politician Teddy we
got it up right there but that dude's a
young Christian warrior for sure yeah
yeah why see the Liberty before yes some
nuts hanging off his eyes whatever from
the top start from the top and Ron
Paul's legit right short Ron Paul's look
jet super rock right here an super crazy
legit and his son is a Rand Paul Rand
awesome yeah crazy [ __ ] though you know
he's also a stand-in double for Tommy
Lee Jones is he Iran yeah Tommy Lee
Jones in this guy looks like he got back
in
please a couple grams Tommy Lee bone so
everybody and thank you for tuning in to
this weekly Kapoor Ronit virus hoaxes
governments love crises because when the
people are fearful they are more willing
to give up freedoms for promises that
the government will take care of them
after 9/11 for example Americans
accepted the near total destruction of
their civil liberties in the Patriot
Act's hollow promises of security hey
Ron Paul go up to Washington dog and
start looking some [ __ ] ready
countermission everyday would be what
saying this [ __ ] every day this isn't
like some new thing he just decided to
you know leave his cabin in the [ __ ]
woods and come on he does this [ __ ]
every day yeah when they what they did
was they're doing the bird right now
they did to him back in the day oh they
leak Aptus [ __ ] they didn't let
him run Bernie's not gonna win man I
know it's crazies out how because they
manipulated completely lied about it
dude have you noticed that you've only
seen one exit poll the whole time so
what that down use exit polls Rukn told
you say that I told you did you know
I've said this whole time that Bernie
was gonna get hijacked man he got
hijacked the last time yeah didn't say
anything took Annie part of the
establishment just we just did a podcast
yesterday tinfoil hat podcast with dr.
Shiva ayyadurai
he's got four degrees from MIT he
invented email this guy's brilliant
brilliant shut up he basically just said
the same thing that ron paul said but he
didn't he wasn't as straight out as ron
paul's coming out rob ball cause this
video the coronavirus hope why is
nothing to lose yeah but so okay so if
it is if it is a hoax not not in the
sense that the virus doesn't exist it's
like the flu yeah it's basically oh baby
all people are dying italy has problems
well the reason is it is a bunch of
you've been a rome it's add people as
people over there [ __ ] do okay I'll
be honest I've never read a DS you like
pizza huh you like pizza yeah okay I'm
not saying the people have worked at
Domino's as [ __ ] I'm saying the
people that works in Roma
pickpocketed they have been shoved but
pushed off a bus or myself carrying some
new bro you dressed like that go ahead
Lee just like what you had a sir for
somebody with a eats bro they look like
war again members from the movie the
Warriors right look like a super-gay
you look like a bouncer at a really
expensive weed stores they both got
cronin well a lot of gay men also say
that it's not getting in the gay
community manager and he approved that
know why I said hoppers nobility [ __ ]
Corona they sniffed the poppers and
they're safe it just seems so bizarre it
seems like it's very calculated who the
media says has it should no media be
held accountable for creating this panic
you don't say it seems to me cuz half of
the people that had died or like almost
half of the people that have died in the
United States still less than a hundred
all come from this elderly folks home in
Washington how weird is that
yeah it seems like is it this other this
other doctor that I listen to on on
YouTube so take it with a grain of salt
he said that coronaviruses is it's not
new it's on the they list it my soul on
the back of lifestyle like is one of the
viruses he kills there's all these
viruses and it says human coronavirus on
the back of Lysol so he's saying this is
nothing new like it 10 years ago they
tested ten thousand people for Corona
you'd get like 40 people because this is
it's they're just rebranding something
that's already out there so I don't know
that people say oh but they got a new
string now and it's mutating it's like
where's the proof of that where the rod
yeah how all mostly do you double chin
look at them right yeah where are the
bodies it's a good question where are
the bodies man we're actors you know me
over here on the streets right now and
you got a hall stay inside cuz the
zombies that's what we're yeah I went
for a jog some guy picked his dog up
when I was jogging by like I was gonna
eat it or so
hard time I was gonna jump on his back
like hey I'm not even joking he picked
it up and walked I got the other side of
this you guys about 201 if you guys
heard of event 201 eventual one is in
October they did this it was like this
kind of meeting where all these great
minds came together and they kind of
talked out what would happen during an
outbreak and it was basically based off
of the coronavirus it's just where Bill
Gates was that Bill Gates's foundation
are basically funded it now if you can
go to arm there's a there's there's one
thing it's called a simulation or
basically they break down what will
happen simulators no no no no it's in
the event 21 you just got event 201 you
just gotta find it where they basically
scenarios find scenarios in this thing
and you breakdown scenario and you read
it exactly no no no sign event it's on
your website read what the scenarios are
I think it's right down there possible
scenarios if you click on site you just
got find out in this website and it's
basically what happened but the opposite
is it here it starts in Latin America
comes to Latin America goes to America
then goes to China but was the other way
around and they talk about how it
started with a bat now when we talked
about dr. Shiva
the reason doesn't believe that is
because they don't know who patient zero
is if you know it came from a bat which
is these wet markets where just these
crazy Asians go and just start eating
live animals and that's what they tried
to say they got from but they don't know
who patient zero is so how do they know
that that's it the scenario now if you
look at the bottom of it it basically or
the read some of it basically comes up
what go down just a little bit go up a
little bit up up on there and it's 18
months point with 65 million but yeah
disease in pig farms yeah go up a little
more yeah I do basically if you read it
talks about bats bats the it's just all
[ __ ] dude and is this but is this
true stuff what do you mean so this is a
scenario this is them going hey just if
somewhere like this or happened this is
how
go down okay and they basically said
exactly what's going on yeah okay that
basically happened right it's also the
movies outbreak right it really is and
let's talk about the fact that Bill
Gates or the DA part of this company
that owns the patent to the virus do you
know that Bill Gates who's been going
around talking like God talking about
how all this could be an epidemic that
kills 65 million people he just happens
to own the patent on this virus and why
do you own the patent on a virus because
if somebody finds a vaccine or cures it
you get paid off of every time it's much
money or need bro yeah why do they keep
doing this kind of stuff to us though if
people are doing this kind of stuff
doing this saying this you know like
just running us through the mill what
are they doing it for this money they do
it dirt when there's a reelection like
they know they feed off our pain and
suffering Jesus Christ the anunnaki dude
lizard people lizard people feed off
they can't create they feed off our pain
and suffering the moon is a an energy
sucker basically it pulls out all of our
energy the moon is not a naturally
satellite it's not a real it's not
natural it doesn't make any sense if you
actually study it it's the only thing in
our universe that makes a perfect orbit
around we never see the other side of
the moon there's there's ancient
cultures to talk about time when there
was no moon wow it's some weird China
just landed on the moon I see that no
one did did they they sent a rover up
there did that yeah the dark side of the
moon you want to believe that you can
well make a song yeah the dark side of
the moon just keep us in thrall with it
like so out there makes no sense why is
that dude the moon is bigger than Pluto
why is it stuck in our orbit why is it
perfectly go in perfect orbit it's too
big to be stuck in our orbit sign so
bring it so sighs sorry so but as far as
the virus goes what are who do you know
anyone that has this am no no I said the
closest is my buddy runs my my board at
my my studio his girlfriend who I've
never met
uh has a her boss has him she's just
trying to get followers yes
that's all she's doing there's a lot of
people yeah a lot of like clout chasing
a lot of disease cloud out there every
comic every sea level comic on Instagram
talking about it clout Roner they're
calling it what's the Asian community
you guys have freaked out now I know you
guys are more freaked I've seen some of
your text messages but Haitians are mad
because they're called to the China
virus yeah but here's Mike when Trump
said China virus I know it's insensitive
but as far as the information he has it
did start in China I mean almost like
that that's why no virus no yeah how
it's not global viruses no [ __ ]
it started in China will you accept we
need the flu will you accept that Oh hot
Jim you know those masks don't do
anything I'm immune
it's for protection for you guys oh do
you have it I got a little bit sniffles
and why do you have a bowling club on or
you go much for my carpal tunnel
actually planning on doing a
class-action suit but where daddy go by
the way I can all this [ __ ] Jesus all
right I'll tell you about to get Corona
next is Ron Paul yeah oh now okay but
what preparations are you taking
personally because you have two young
children yeah and I bought two
generators I bought [ __ ] ton of water
[ __ ] ton of chicken I got two guns yeah
well you're good what about the kids
though you have formula you got diapers
on everything I got I got a baby I got a
bunch of porn
I got toilet paper to wipe my ass okay
right Graceland I got diapers I got I
got a baby's mama with the biggest
utters you'll ever see really nice big
some big all the huge ones if we all
make money we can make some money you
know life and other fans only dot-com
huh dude that's what we're talking about
Mami's oh yeah mammy holler corona Becky
that shoot they're like big black tits
you ever seen chicks black chicks with
big man me is that it I got a white girl
with big man kissing nipples big nipples
yeah dude that is their car they're uh
Golden Corral
for the kids that's right he's go there
where'd you go dude I took a piss
respect man that was a long piss the
longest you guys miss me yeah
do you notice this though do you notice
little things like I noticed like so
I'll be in my kitchen and I'll usually
let's have a glass by the sink where
I'll just fill it up with water and
drink it you know whenever I need some
water right what are you drinking tap
water
yeah I've been drinking tap water to
what proper drinking since I was born
well that's all I know I mean so it
helps you guys drink tap water
my whole family drinks it oh yeah we've
been born and raised on this Ola tap
water kidding I was a Java guffaws
you're kidding no way no how much
chlorine they put in that I feel hopeful
lot yeah I hope I could use a little fly
you guys know I'm sorry ballers would be
bottled water no all I plus a boy you
have a filter on it absolutely not what
straight from the dead kid iam of course
he doesn't he still takes creatine yeah
are your energy for days freshen up
radioactive at this point you're crazier
than you but yeah I do drink it but
here's what I'm saying is now I notice
when I go get the glass by the sink I'm
Mike I start thinking like oh man is my
glass too dirty like it's something
wrong with like it definitely like this
whole thing is infected my psyche like
the doctors my I will be like maybe in
the morning like it oh yeah something
I'd be like oh my god am I gonna die
like in my Azam like oh you're gonna die
you're drinking tap water watching too
much news bro but all of these guys
watch the news do you watch CNN I don't
watch CNN now wait what what I watch it
cool
i watch a gamma okay a bunch of HLN CNN
i watch the fox news i just want to know
what what kind of prop
again to the spit Nimet it's ridiculous
I don't know where else I rewatched
impose various which I know you guys
hate but where would you where would you
get your news where should I get my news
if people I listen that's or like I
watch you know what's wrong with that
where should they get their news
watching CNN it's important just to see
what they're doing I can't thank you
it's so bad after a while you're like
damn you don't just don't you know
[ __ ] coming out of CNN well their
problem is they're so bias against Trump
so it's just like [ __ ] dude yeah but you
say slides the last four years they've
lied about everything they lied about
listing grab her by the [ __ ] they glide
about a Russian collision no but they
they the way they edited it yeah that's
not what he said he goes you can even
grab them by the puss you talking about
groupies and which is correct groupies
it's a grandmother [ __ ] okay a groupie
a lot of people rupee rather let you it
of course they're a groupie anyhow and
who put their [ __ ] on your hand while
you're looking the other one I'm ringing
doorbells you know what the [ __ ] going
on meet him for a butterscotch or
something next thing you know I'm time
[ __ ] hey who was the guy who's the
interviewer Billy what Billy really yeah
he got fired but he's back now oh yes oh
they fired him why he got fired for that
yeah he was on the Trump [ __ ] oh oh
yeah he's like you know bringing it up
now hold me to thing wasn't meant to
take out all these people that ended up
just taking out people in Hollywood then
you go to AA Syria Iran Syria that
they're gonna kill all the Kurds
Syria he's BA he's gassing his own
people then it went to the Ukraine quote
pro quo which was tolai and now we're at
coronavirus and why is they won't
believe in this [ __ ] [ __ ] well I
think people are mean people I think
there's two things just one of like
believing in and then there's another of
having to live within the confines of
what's going on you know what they are
right don't you just think about that
but it would be the first when I get
when the average
age of the people done in the United
States it goes from 80 to 50 is the
average age dad I'm gonna start to worry
then I'll sir okay maybe this [ __ ] is
legit I'm with it right now it's 80 I'm
with it you know I'm thinking I'm
thinking like where you getting these
numbers it's like then I bet like you
know the infectious disease center they
get it calls you know and like a
infectious disease and like someone says
yeah over here an oak Oak Ridge old
convalescent home we got two more dead
bodies you know what they died of the
Rona okay the Rome yeah dude Rome you
know we got three people dead there you
know one was 107 one was 96 and one was
115 and they all died of flu
complications ago okay thank you boom
Rona run maybe were there you know Tony
Rumore Rona McDonald got him Tony Roma's
got him before I could say it Anna eat
like it that's the thing it's just
there's no well the news became so
unreliable I feel like over the last
three years
oh yeah that now it that's that that's
one of the scariest things is now it's
like now everyone believes them you know
what I mean everybody knows they
established we saw all their lies the
Russian collusion lies I mean you know
what's what's going on right now
during the corona it crona's at its
height you know what's going on right
now the Biden's are being investigated
in the Senate behind closed doors that's
what's going on you don't hear my best
yet because if the Biden's go down a lot
of these [ __ ] we're doing the
same scam a lot of them were doing this
so that's why they're all protecting
Biden because of Biden [ __ ] on video
video yeah so they got yeah that [ __ ]
corn pop that guy Venona vines losing is
gonna buy - potatoes brother compromise
also had a multiple facelifts oh yeah no
phony look like [ __ ] next him not my boy
by then he went Hollywood and his she's
like yeah he looks like Leatherface
right yes run off right now right now
the Biden's that whole bite is grand
they all been doing that [ __ ] all the
people that are like screaming
there they're involved in all worried
they get their kids involved they get
the kids and they put them on an Energy
Board Oh in some foreign country they
never the kid never goes in that country
maybe once a year first he'd never get
anything and they're on a board and they
get 80k a month they all direction
that's why they're protecting bottom
because the Biden goes down a lot of
them are dominating the same yeah
that's why they got to protect by they
can by the way yeah up with Michelle
Obama yeah Madeline right yeah not only
is not only is that going down but we're
oh you know what all else is going down
oh now they're going back and going okay
the Russian collusion thing they try to
they try to paint Trump out as a Russian
spy now they're going back got who
started this piece by piece and who
started put who got the FISA warrants
who got the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance warrants how'd they get it
who lied that's what do people are
getting busted
so right now Corona smashing nobody's
paying attention on let's also take a
look at scar owners crushing all of it
right now
what is trunk done what is Trump Plaza
Trump is getting us trying to get us out
of Syria trying to guess how Afghanistan
they're doing their best to stop that
dude is in a trade war with China and
pulled out of this Paris climate Accord
now if nobody ever talks about this do
you know what this Paris climate climate
court was it was basically that you were
able to put out this much co2 if you
didn't if you put out more co2 than that
you had to buy credits so it's never
about curbing emissions you want make it
about but so this wall group called the
Club of Rome right was gonna make
trillions of dollars on this because as
a court wasn't meant to stop anything it
was gonna be like pharmaceutical
companies where they don't cure a
patient they keep you for life they
don't get rid of it you have it for the
rest of your life you have to buy
medication all the time same thing for
this Club of Rome they were gonna get
trillions and trillions of dollars and
now he got out of that he's [ __ ] so
what so now he's in a trade war with
China and he's in this and he got out of
this club of wrong [ __ ] which is now
they're out of Switzerland right now but
they started
Italy what else is in Italy the Vatican
the Pope all this crazy pedophile [ __ ]
so where are the two places that are hit
the hardest with this coronavirus China
and Italy dude you don't know that yes I
just learned I know that oh really it
all comes down to this you took control
a nation in my eyes you want to keep
they all know this all he's got it he's
got it dude he's got a head finally if
somebody CEO years ago he's seen as
here's ago he scores he's headed years
ago was about to say is the way you
control masses you want to you want to
be a dictator you want to rule the world
or rule your little world your little
country you got to keep constantly
scaring the people with [ __ ] only the
government can save you from they only
scaring you ship with [ __ ] only the
government can say global warming only
the government could save you pay it
some global tax a global tax on carbon
aliens them asteroids they want to scare
us with asteroids Oh who's gonna save
some asteroids your neighbor or the
government the government right yeah
Jesus pandemics who's gonna save you
your neighbor or the government the
government so they got to keep scaring
you [ __ ] terrorism who's gonna save you
the government aliens alien the big one
though the biggest one is the fake alien
invasion that's when they pull that off
you just a could do it now look at what
they did with the corona you don't think
they could do that [ __ ] with aliens
people have I think more as the tightest
bought a six gauge and a [ __ ] Beretta
dude come on that's coming off a Caelian
invasion they've been preparing us for
that they just don't know when to pull
the trigger cuz huh when they pull the
trigger good they can't back out they
better look like justice yeah I better
know a little peep climbing out of a
[ __ ] tour bus teenage pop stars the
tattoos on oh and that's the ultimate
scare they're not gonna be able to do it
this time though I think people are too
advanced I think we're getting close I
think well with the hollow good enough
you know they're hologram technology
you're just put up a big-ass [ __ ] you
just put it up just for fine fat
everyone all right everyone videotape
Miskin and then you turn it off
oh you know what I mean oh we just went
away just some SuperSpeed and unreal
what do you got maybe just do this again
you know like those little red light you
can just do that boom and it's a big
[ __ ] spaceship mothership on the
inward that's all air inward yeah people
say Italy because like they got all
these accursed islets you know with with
their radars and and all that [ __ ] and
the footage always looks like these
pilots right garbage these military
pilots I think I think they believe
they're seeing crazy and they don't know
why would they be I can be better if
they weren't in on it and we fooled the
pilot or maybe there's like like some
hologram that they're fooling pirate
pilots on so there's a Pat's behind
talked about it they're letting them
talk about it they let them talk about
here let them talk about yeah Paula's
our disguise that way they're the Air
Force guys I've gotta go to I saw some
[ __ ]
we saw some shadows Instagram thoughts
tried charging area 51 yeah I think
there's a rebellion building in the
background there were a lot of people
are just like look I'm not gonna listen
anymore of this [ __ ] little by little
what happens is when you wake up you
can't go back to sleep you can pretend
you're asleep but you can't go back to
sleep once you figure out your buddy you
have this friend for five years and he's
from it's true yeah yes you can write
out everything about his life that he
told you is a [ __ ] lie yeah when you
find out that how did you know when you
find that out
you look at him differently now now you
don't believe [ __ ] he says well there's
one thing there's nothing you can say or
do to change your state of mind right
you can still be friends with them but
yeah yeah you got Nick let's get into
the show here guys let the show huh no
dog fan submit question to have the
tempo hat podcast here Sam Tripp our own
Eddie Bravo and
thank you guys so much for coming in man
trying time I love I love doing a
goddamn podcast thanks love it you're so
open-minded you know too many times you
don't shut [ __ ] down you're just
open-minded well I'm just curious man I
just don't want to be I don't like being
taken advantage of that's what I don't
like you know like it like you that's
all I'm about ain't trying to change
[ __ ] I just taking lied to ya at a
certain point you yeah you gotta just
[ __ ] wake up and go okay these
[ __ ] are awful issue how many
times you gotta be right listen dude if
we were wrong all the time will we be
doing this will we be doing tours we'll
be doing any of that stuff no man it's
like jujitsu I took it for three weeks I
tapped Keenen Ivory Wayans I called it a
day right I got in God didn't I got out
I wasn't good at it my buddy Scott was
great at now he's got his own dojo right
if we weren't good at this we wouldn't
be doing it I mean what's our batting
average 900 950 I mean what if it was
wrong man I stayed up the other night
watching uh some of your uh fights Eddie
well YouTube I was on with the jujitsu
mattress yeah yeah which one it was
crazy man though well the one that I was
like the Gracie one man horse I didn't
know how close y'all men get to each
other during all of engines vary and you
guys are locked in there like a little
8-ball yeah I'm like dude it's like
you're that patient
yeah dude you got the biggest thing
patient but it was awesome and it's
awesome just see like the interviews and
stuff it was cool oh man it's in my
system right now they should be in
everybody's system right now with the
world going crazy you know what you need
some greens man maybe can't go this
storm by that head of lettuce maybe
can't buy some spinach put some carrots
are there's no sockets yeah maybe you
can't get those beets maybe you can't
get those
zucchinis no but you can get some
athletic greens ultimate daily all in
one athletic drink with 75 vitamins for
that body that bout it that athletic
greens they got everything you need in
there they have five critical areas of
health including energy immunity gut
health
whoa hormonal and neural support and
healthy aging that's a bonus cat ago
yeah get your mind right get your body
even riders I'm not gonna relapse but
it's gonna be close
all right greens doesn't compromise on
ingredients in sourcing its gluten-free
dairy-free keto paleo and vegan friendly
no GMOs or funny additives it is trusted
by some of the world's top performers
entrepreneurs
athletes and all I'm peons yeah man so
take the right step and getting healthy
with all the craziness going on athletic
greens takes guesswork out of everyday
good health why not just try it jump on
over to athletic greens calm /ke 80s
claim the special offer today 20 free
travel packs value at $79 with your
first purchase that's athletic greens
comp /k ATS yes athletic greens calm
safe Katz listen guys everybody needs
some help and anxiety bro do you dates
are cancelled everybody coughing army of
anxiety dude yeah can't get to the
therapist microwaves broken Oh
Cinnabon won't deliver yes and runs out
of Center they said like eat the hots
out of pizza yeah yes hot it's a subway
out of the way if somebody is yelling a
hut on the phone when you cut high now
I'll take a large cheese pizza how that
I look we're saying that people are
having tough times and if there's
something interfering with your
happiness or that's preventing you from
achieving your goals then better help
will address your needs and assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist it's
better help be ET ter heelp better help
there's a broad range of expertise and
better helps counselor network which may
not be locally available in many areas
if you live in the Congo if you live in
a room outside of Akron if you live
somewhere on top of Mount Rushmore yeah
on the bottom of Mount Rushmore you
might not be able to get help so better
help offers services for people that
need therapy and there's a bunch of
different ways you can use them you know
I've been on better health before and
I've connected with my therapist and
then I can do FaceTime with my therapist
from my car from the side of the road
yeah sometimes I just do it I'll just do
face on my face and go hi
and ice hang up let her know I feel good
yes he likes it it's more affordable
than traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available better he'll
want you to start living a happier life
today visit their website and read their
testimonial that are posted daily okay
visit better help calm /ke 80s that's
better help at calm / k 80s enjoying the
over 700,000 people taking charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional there's a
special offer as well for cats listeners
you get 10% off your first month at
better help calm / cats some I hadn't
seen before
what's this little bit takers Krav Maga
anyway we got a corona ribeye a corona
virus related king under sting it ok hey
guys I'm Erin from Vancouver Washington
and I've got a king at our sting it for
you coronavirus themed pickup lines
anyways thanks for keeping us
entertained through all this Gang Gang
buzz buzz and he's got some examples ok
corona pickup lines yeah I'll be the
covet you'd be the 19 cuz together I
think we'd make a pretty sick couple
yeah I tested positive for being your
next boyfriend haha kid names Aaron off
the burning in my chest is a symptom of
the corona virus or it's just the
feelings I get from seeing you two to
240 all I know is that someone will
[ __ ] with those lines that's where
we've got a society we've really
bottomed out in terms of [ __ ] man I
don't think that those people aren't
digging those lines man I think some of
these thirst traps would they're sitting
out at home right now taking picture of
their ass get on the damn girl you look
sick she freaks out like not that body
sick yeah yeah and roll right over
quarantine up with some home these
chicks are freaking out they're gonna
die alone pussy's never been more
bargain-basement I just got out your
shop right what if what if they
Korona is easily transmitted through
sperm we're on number spraying on
[ __ ] no more creating your own
sink like I concentrated in sperm and
then you butthole absorbs like I don't
want to bring kids into this sick world
right right Anil is probably at all-time
high
yeah Nino's people crushing that ass ass
is bad because for a while hey cuz when
I was growing up like 80s 90s if your
girl didn't give up the ass like at
least once a year you break up with her
and everyone would understand but these
days Anil so dead right now
no nobody divorce their wife because
they don't give a maim no but in the
eighties yeah you go to the judge you
could you go to the judge and say you
know it's overrated
it's best to threaten like your
girlfriend you thought right [ __ ] I'm
gonna put it in your ass and just the
serial oh wow justice year
yeah the threat that's all I want yeah
and then you threaten with like you put
a little thumb in there like I get bit
you gotta trust that ass if you don't
trust that ass why put a condom oh my
first my thumb first before I thought
try to put it into something you put a
condom on your thumb wow man how's that
going what do you guys do if you guys
are venturing into the dark of dark web
the dark web or you mean that talk about
Koreatown yeah baby
first of all we make sure they take a
good [ __ ] and then shower Wow and then I
respect that man before you hop run to
the bathroom and she does some NASCAR
[ __ ] on her [ __ ] get in there clean
all out throw a little spray on that
that's all I'm looking for
hey back up like maybe 16 years ago oh
yeah
first time years ago I here's gonna turn
out one of my students produced like
bottom-of-the-barrel born like it was
only I know that only he was a
penitentiary category I'm poor no bottom
the bare office say no I didn't really
know at that point I just nearly produce
porn so I thought damn like you know he
must be getting a lot of hot chicks you
know what I mean
right talk about it I didn't know the
level and then I said dude a you know if
I ever could hang out on the set I'd
love to hang out you know I'm like oh
[ __ ] I'm a gold set oh yeah hi every got
hot go our installer be an orgy and I'm
like I want so we invite amigos hey dude
come on dick come on down there's I'm
filming at this place in in like when
Hannah Rama City yeah I'm like okay so
do that with Stoke focus orgy where
would you wear I don't remember what I
wore but I don't remember what I wore
but you're a rock hard driving oh I get
there I stood I was gone dude I slept
the [ __ ] I got on my ground was gone and
then he called me on the I'm on the
[ __ ] 405 getting a [ __ ] out of there
and he calls where'd you go bro she
wants to [ __ ] you I'm like dude sorry
thank y'all take a rain check
were you going she wants to [ __ ] you yes
no dude that was gone are you surprised
at porn so it wants to [ __ ] that's kind
of what they do you want to see our
sausage made Eddie No hey one time I was
it wasn't what I imagined was it it's
cool low level do low level I went to a
porn shoot nad catering there is a
caterer that sounds like Andrew Blake's
that sounds nice what else you like that
good porn
wait we did we answer yeah we did we you
stung the pickup line you say no I and I
like it I think in the time crisis I
think people use a little humor these
girls are locked up bored of [ __ ] I'm
locked up yeah they are
I think that women are not
any sex or anything like that right now
I think everybody shutting it down
I think people are gonna be a lot of
Corona baby how do they all think there
are I guarantee I'm juggling mule in
their homes right now let's start living
brother yeah ha get out comb your hair
live some life I didn't have watch show
some pride but what else yeah I was hard
what do we got this this guy's quickly
become regular
alright boys no sports it's the guy was
at the hockey games Otis
so we're anything it's toric paramount
pictures backlot st. Patrick's Day we
got the quarantine for the coronavirus
going on you know got a lot of options
my friends so King it or sting it a
movie studios on st. Patty's Day
coronavirus baby what do you say I don't
even know what his question is venturing
into things you can't get into usually
what because the virus is going on I
think yeah I think going Astrid you guys
hear about Philadelphia the cops are
like the crime have fun oh yeah we
arresting anybody yeah you could do
drugs
bang hookers doesn't matter go hard in
the paint to us man young dude that's
blue let's do show up there let's go
come on I'll do a show if we can be
armed on the stage man yeah oh it's the
purge but once you start that then other
people came back alright I'm having my
gun whoever comes to my door is gonna
die you know yeah - welcome to the purge
dude will you pair drugs in Philly right
now I'm not doing drugs right now if
people need to be killed or I'm not no
I'll be sober for that nice went up
stone to a freaking purge yeah I don't
want any drugs on my suspect yeah you
got a shop with a gun
you guys have weapons or not about a six
gauge and I bought a um Beretta hell
yeah
how many guns you got about six that's a
liar's number dude so I have six guns oh
he's four years old I got three upstairs
and the same I got two in the living
room I got one in the garage into the
living room next to the remote little
entertainment area with another safe you
ever have any guns
yeah us to change the channel
shotgun like a massage shotgun
what's this [ __ ] beautiful human
being say Nordic resident job
Theodore von Hopi boys are doing well
down there in Southern California it's
Alex coming from you up here in the
Sacramento Valley okay boarding supplies
with this coronavirus went to Costco got
some light supplies didn't want afford I
thought it'd be rude for the older
people and younger people what are you
guys doing are you guys hoarding
supplies light supplies going out
everyday getting what you need let us
know love you guys
love you beautiful great yeah guy
probably does [ __ ] drag [ __ ] too you
know they could drag queens skin oh wait
that dude is way hotter than my
girlfriend junior high school girlfriend
my junior highschool girlfriend was
really tough oh yeah she used to pick me
up and give me a [ __ ] kiss and stuff
at after school
what was her name huh pick you up and
kiss you yeah she picked me up and all
the other kids would see it on the bus
and they came by and there was nothing I
could do Rowe she was so much bigger
than me she would pick me up and wrap my
legs around her hell you kiss me it was
so [ __ ] rough but she was alright
look Jamie Lee Curtis have a dick no
they said she was born or never night
after that yeah did she have a nub I
don't think so I saw her True Lies I've
seen her person she's a beautiful thing
yeah okay what's this guy sent hoarding
what do you guys do I'm not I mean I
load up on some stuff so I'm straight
with the kiddos but I'm not hoarding
like I went to go buy meat you know cuz
I'm in that weird diet that carnivore
diet you're always on something yeah
always dude when you just go live your
life yeah I'm living brother oh but I
would I shop stop oh my god I'm on my
deathbed damn he's leaning is the lady
in front of me try buying all the meat
all the meat at this market at this
butcher and the dude was like this ain't
happening look at all those people
behind
you think enough selfish a dish she just
got to look out for my knees like ain't
how it matter if I get out of here
really and she but she only got three
pounds of meat and that's it now that's
what they should do three pounds of meat
I think is very good at the butcher he's
like killing you three pounds three
pounds and three pieces of meat or some
[ __ ] like that
it's Cuba baby welcome to Cuba I know
you know they say the economy's tanking
because it's all but not for everybody
yeah I'll think about that the CEO of
Charmin then what [ __ ] buying Islands
everywhere oh and also I notice they put
toilet paper then cotton balls when the
toilet paper is out and then q-tips or
people wipe their asses you know I was
shocked when I first found out about the
toilet paper thing I went to Costco and
I had no idea this is right at the
beginning I didn't know about the toilet
paper frenzy but I didn't even think
about it we get to Costco I'm thinking
[ __ ] there's not gonna be any food it's
gonna be [ __ ] empty we walk in and
there's a sign no water no toilet paper
and you know you know of course no water
makes sense you're stranded in a desert
you're [ __ ] all you're thinking about
is water you ain't thinking about [ __ ]
you ain't even thinking about your kids
you're thinking about your [ __ ] water
right that makes sense
food some kind of food should be number
two yeah you know what I mean
toilet paper should be like 23rd right
you know what I mean yes but it was
[ __ ] second and that crazy so
straight like I was like how important
sense wait am I gonna make us jump in
the shower I know I won't jump with the
shower
they're not gonna brainwash me into
jumping in the shower and cleaning my
ass we're gonna figure this out my boy
come on this propaganda my boy counter
washes ass in the sink I seen in
restaurants I take a [ __ ] why jumps on
the sink and washes his ass like a sick
bird dude yeah they used to say wash
your hand and I was young they would say
wipe your hand with your ass wash your
hand in the sink Wow yeah we're out of
toilet
oh is that Louisiana that's how they did
their I mean I just think if you didn't
have any toilet paper you so you reach
in and just scoop it out and then go
wash your hands and then at some point
your ass if your hand right your hands a
straight-a student
that's why Katrina I was a B student
down I see D student I'm [ __ ] but no
you would smell your hand bro on you
would [ __ ] wipe your ass yeah then
wash your hand and just go not Warner's
now hi everybody would stink and like
radioactive and chip that's a difference
between us you guys look too far in her
things man you guys are still smelling
the [ __ ] that's why God that's why God
hit you in country what do you got I got
a walker yes we get your hand those
levees [ __ ] snap what do you think
here Jim what are you guys doing y'all
[ __ ] in your hand over there what
are you guys I'm stationed just squat on
the sidewalk and drop deuces oh they got
the best squats you see I'm hanging out
got squat down low I bet the [ __ ] just
[ __ ] flows out yeah you know and how
golden like in these times how golden
are perfect shits these days right Wow
no those shits will you [ __ ] and you
wipe your ass and no [ __ ] oh no he's in
for that
I always know Corona or not but right
now that's more important than ever than
perfect shits make me believe in God
it's me get to it you got to relax and
take deep breaths and and you got it's
hard not to clench that but don't cut it
off it's hard so you got its you gotta
figure out how to just get into that
zone and just breathe huge it ever takes
like a two-foot [ __ ] it just keeps going
oh yeah you wanna like cut it off but
you're like [ __ ] you sake
yeah but do you think it knows but then
you gotta think you just gotta focus you
gotta think Corona what do you got Nick
hi guys this is Nick's sister Doreen
Kovac 19 should you use all the toilet
paper or invest in a bidet Gang Gang
buzz-buzz
respect that the days she runs a bodega
be huge she does the booty please right
Nick high colonic yes yeah it's just 105
no flavors distilled water only don't
get a twist it's just water the finest
in all day a little raspberry your
coffee enemas are the best - for
cleaning your ass well I got preventive
you do with coffee enemas new launder
once a week you probably won't get colon
cancer gene oh yeah once a week hey can
we just some people do it three times a
week
can we acknowledge Nyx's are pretty high
me let's just let's just get the
elephant out of the room we're not
hitting on people that work with us this
sister dude haven't you read the
freaking forms I sent you HR like care
huh oz HR like it's loose this will be
played in court
hopefully they played a full episode in
court
hmm and here's a young guy that
obviously is into other men I will say
this dude when you are going through
Korona times like you judge people
immediately in your brain out safety and
for everything you know dude god bless
you if you have that gay dollar dude
that's why this podcast is killing it
you got that gay dollar dude and they
gave dollar days those will income today
guys Bonin don't got kids they just buy
cars and buy sking in a sting merch
that's all they buy well not yet Johnson
- this guy looks like he plays lacrosse
at Duke on big club question for you
guys sex with a face mask on let's go
doggy style you don't need a face it's
only water dude this guy's very
perverted from MIT about doggy style
yesterday reverse cowgirl that's like
you don't need a mask
Londyn reverse doggystyle you're good oh
now the condoms are off yeah I'll call
you back
no no condoms are back in no no they
were even the 80s are you getting [ __ ]
they cut roaches were they big dude you
know what was they had their stock was
like IBM level Trojan discuss AIDS is
poppin everybody's wax is still poppin
oh my god but now nobody nobody uses
condoms anymore now nobody eight is like
the flu yeah yeah if these don't really
condom now you almost get scared yeah
what are they hiding
what are they home with you via Magic
Johnson sometime to AIDS help you out
yeah that's true
what else you got Nick we get who knows
what could happen what was that guy's
problem
he said sex were with a mask on well
let's go to chairman let's go to the
freakin obviously cook the the maestro
himself right here Jim Woody's the
Mortal Kombat yeah
nothing out with the mask on when having
sex you already having sex so you look
like a [ __ ] mine or one of those
miners I got stuck in behind so alright
oh you guys you'll mask sex out there no
but it actually sounds like a maybe kind
of a fetish thing I think that is
honestly a genre on pornhub now Korona
porn people are [ __ ] with masks on
Wow hi there tough to breathe in though
you know huh
those masks are tough to breathe in well
there's how hot are you
hey dude if you're doing porn with a
mask on there'd be a lot of dudes who
are willing to do porn like it disguises
guys they're like normal dudes doing
[ __ ] porn with little dicks
I saw a guy on the plane had on a
Raggedy Andy mask he didn't even have on
a like a mass like that it's like a
literally I don't a Halloween like he's
about to rob a bank and some yeah I saw
I saw one dude at their pro just a
welder's mask on yeah I saw a dude walk
around the whole like four
in steel knight costume on like he was
about to that's great a castle that's
yeah like like straight out of yeah dude
it's getting crazy bro I saw do walk
around with some astronaut [ __ ] like you
just got back from the move people are
freaking out what do you got Nick it's
okay that we wear the masks the kids
doll and we got a cat around here
somewhere
should we put a mask on the cat is gonna
be a serial killer
surely that dudes gonna kill it's a new
family that kid's gonna kill and like
five of those cats point yes oh he's
back there going why so serious to the
point though it is a Boomer virus I know
people hate to hear that but it's taking
out the Boomers don't know kids that
fast well it's taking out Trump voters
too that's another thing it's taking on
don't hide in butters your fan base yeah
that's a good question what do you guys
think mass on the just the adults are
the kids listen dude you didn't make
more kids save yourself this coming from
a new father this from the guy who's
like yeah I loaded up on stuff for no
beef jerky oh the good stuff wow so
you're saying just a mass on the
adults-only yeah well do when they say
like if the oxygen level of the plane
air pressure goes the mask you know put
it on yourself though first don't worry
about the kids if you actually like them
there's a lot of parents out there
freaking out that they got to hang out
with their kids all day know and the
kids the kids don't understand
what's going on there no you know what I
suggest [ __ ] and sit your kids down
you're getting sick of him sit him down
scare the [ __ ] out of them with
contagion put that movie Contagion
outbreak scare the [ __ ] out of them then
[ __ ] tell him you got a quarantine
lock them in their room yeah you got it
we got a quarantine everyone's got it
corns you got dad how long a couple
weeks you know in LA do some messages
every now and then in Viet soon you're
like you give them their [ __ ] their
ID Cheerios and [ __ ] in a hazmat suit
just like PO you got to stay in the room
the door make a prison lockup still
understand deal it'll shut down shut
down till September September dude
that's it may now you want September I
know I [ __ ] up yeah who do you work
for
no no dude a lot of bad news coming up
in every year September hey dude
everybody knows you were learning
through your son a little bit we
mushrooms stuck inside for a couple
weeks scared of the krona what's he's on
all of them nothing
yeah he said all the above D all the
above
ah I don't need more panic I don't take
mushrooms and start freaking the [ __ ]
out watching what was the last time you
did shroom yeah it's a good question
three four years ago I microdose and did
hot yoga and just stared at the yoga
instructors to ask for the entire hour
even though they told me to stop really
yeah could we go please out front big
boy mm-hmm I just stayed in one position
for the time that microdose and people
use that effectively oh yeah I've never
in my career hey you know what I've
taken a couple stems I guess you can
call that micro dosing but the real trip
on mushrooms there is 5 grams that's the
real truck that's what Terence Mckenna
says that don't do I think that's that
that's like a
MT Tripp you do five grams put her in a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich
boom I've done deal I've done DMT I love
peanut butter Lee I didn't hit the
[ __ ] zoo freak the [ __ ] did the zoo
I know five grams why would you do
mushrooms ed I do I wasn't no I thought
it was a great idea let's go to the zoo
check out the animals loved by the
prisoners but then right when it hits
dude like oh my god
all these animals are [ __ ] depressed
they're in jail and then you just want
to run I just want her to run out of the
[ __ ] and I'm disabled Tiger jumping I
was [ __ ] up dude that was the wrong
place to be soo is the last place you
want to be the monkeys look like there
were just suicide were you with your
family no I was with your boyfriend
that's the way to do with a female okay
I went to the world fear I would use
about right dad be like those are the
friend Eddie what about this so did the
animals did you feel like a relationship
to the animals like did you feel like
yes I made eye contact like oh this
[ __ ] feels our pain oh I do feel
your [ __ ] there's a polar bear they
gotta do their polar bear exhibit is
like built in 1920 or something dude
it's like this white [ __ ] supposed to
be like an iceberg and there's a white
door where the guys come out to feed the
polar bear yeah and that polar bear was
just pacing back by that door back and
forth would not stop just pacing back
they go insane like that yeah that's a
sign of them losing their mind but did
you feel like we were from animals more
do you feel like we're related to each
other at all I doubt they okay
I felt like oh [ __ ] they're all on that
grass bad I don't need that Noah's Ark
America's largest water park then how'd
that go it was the best day of my life
did you take your trunks off nope kept
them on I did shrooms at the World
Series which was which series uh when
the Dodgers got [ __ ] by the Astros the
cheating ass Astros I did this during
one time with this dude Lonnie's party
and uh and I thought think I've told the
story I gave him out to everybody then
we played hiding goes
can people had never done him before so
like 30 people ate him for the first
time started a game of hide-and-go-seek
and didn't see him nobody found some
people never never seen let's live never
seen relevant this is a good old days
man look at this guy this guy looks
homeless it's like one of my cousins it
really is up the oh I'm Brendon
Sheboygan here in Indiana on the
lockdown of quarantine I'm so bored I
resorted to Washington Theo
I got a keen understanding for ya
inviting a new girlfriend to chill at
your place for the whole entire
quarantines Kenya or sting sting the
whole time
nah bro just a little dash here and then
one whole time I'm gonna be like so four
months I mean if it's a girl you are in
love with yes you know what I mean but a
girl that you're not in love with as
soon as you not dude you're gonna want
to [ __ ] kick her out
jump out of goddamn one yeah that's a
bad she might be able to cook and she's
staying out the whole time right she but
I have some supplies that dudes for
serious man he's a Cubs fan you can see
that Cubs and when he's got in the back
said eyebrows on him we sink in his Inc
that's a good question yeah would you
invited yeah you can't invite a girl
over for that long no you guys really
good yeah yeah you don't know from
chickens you not she start all your [ __ ]
I wish you had AIDS load up your
bathroom eat all your [ __ ] oh yeah
bigger you all your [ __ ] they better
bring some [ __ ] that's what I'm saying
come over supplies they bring some
something you got to watch them eat it
you know you do dude you get a ball you
give her coke sheets nothing a couple
days every times about the old bed to
give her another gak ur sheets not good
she scrubs the whole house run math to
be clean brainstorming
what do you want to do when you're on
math clean yeah that's true
meth heads ain't gonna get no corona
yeah that's true yeah we didn't want to
go Bob Vila on a house when their
[ __ ] moon speed dude the smoke speed
and fix your cabinet speed and put a
porch on your poor thing you know you
got a hot tub you got a chimney with a
hot tub
[Laughter]
bringing your apocalypse why aren't home
nobody's picking up home as people
nobody there's no no the dirtiest
[ __ ] ever get up homeless
Pyrrhus nobody's bro I'm jogging in my
neighborhood homeless guy goes yep the
virus come and I'm still homeless
thank you better where's he where's he
getting information about the virus oh
dude the homeless nowadays they got
iPhones dude it's true there's on
Ventura there's these two famous
homeless people their brothers two
transgender brothers on wheelchairs they
live on Ventura
they live on venture with purple wigs
other plans no no they live longer
they're on their phones all the time no
they're famous there's a there's a gas
station a 76 station on the corner of
Van Nuys Boulevard and Ventura and
there's a bus stop right in front of
that gas station they've been living
there for a couple years now
now they moved over like about three or
four stores west of Van Nuys on Ventura
there's a store that is no longer in
business it's called saffron or
something and they got like a little
patio they took that [ __ ] over there
there every day to transgender rotting
homeless old dudes they got purple wigs
on and everything you know know me but
they don't shave they got they fought
for that those rights those transgender
rights and they don't even shave that
doesn't make any sense yeah you follow
me all those right all right you have
the wigs though they wear the wig oh
that's a
they gotta have know I think I think you
know what if if you claim and
transgender you shave your [ __ ] face
come on put some makeup on you fought
for those rights
you got those rights but you know take
care of your face get a facial every now
and you got it - yeah I can see that
absolutely no makeup on I'm surprised
that's not a TV show give him facials
the homeless trans people
yeah beautifying the homeless but he's I
think why are the government why are we
a lot wire homeless people seem like
they would be able to be easily carriers
of this based on like let's stab each
other just based on how filthy they are
and they're not even picking they're not
they're ignoring them yes well how weird
is that
do we have anybody has the disease they
would get it first maybe the first ones
to get it yeah I have to spread it and
they're just you know they're talking
about downtown's got like medieval
plagues like medieval time plagues
they're talking about going on downtown
dude I want to do a bunch of coke with
and [ __ ] attack medieval times when
they're performing dude dress up like a
rival gang Black Knight I want to know
where all these [ __ ] came from
the bottoms they're like over the last
June Street here in like where do they
come from and they're all white you know
what I mean like what is going on like
what I would like someone to go out and
interview a whole shitload of them and
get something for me yeah where are you
because nobody listen nobody listens to
him because they're crazy no one ever
wants to talk to him that never maybe
they got some crazy stories what if
they're telling the truth and put
together these stores or you guys coming
what happened how did you end up on the
streets yeah in attempt to culture
corner we could do it we picked up one
time we were doing an arm it was when
America's Got Talent
started it we did America's Got Talent
at loyola marymount and they said on the
way over there we were just hosting at
me and a buddy of mine for their
students and they said okay we'll pick
up get some judges and we said okay we
picked up two homeless guys bro named
Tony and Rich from the Lincoln and
Wilshire Park that parked that's right
there Reed Park well we just rolled up
or like dude $40 each if you guys just
have to be cool go on stage can you
judge some people that are performing
like yeah we're good do we roll up the
curtains opens like 1,100 students and
Tony and rich [ __ ] judges
and we go well it grow but except for
during the inter what we have when we
had to tabulate the vote you had to take
a few minutes so Tony was like a let me
bar that get talking that guy that got
up there and let me play something dude
and he got up there and literally said
bro Oh rifted but you get a couple
chords dude and drop some serious
[ __ ] racial slurs and that's when it
got a little spicy
but are you is this dude yeah this was
probably 2001 okay you could do that
yeah but the man it was crazy and Tony
died and rich is still alive I see him
sometimes biking to the parks in my
house I he don't remember me yeah what
else you got Nick we got one flaunt my
aunt what and praise God brother thanks
for sending in the video thank you guys
you got the girl in your place man I
think it's gonna be a long run for a lot
of awkward breakfasts survival ration
that survival food [ __ ] Infowars
with that [ __ ] sushi powdered powdered
scrambled eggs
hope hope you'll have lizzo as a side
view Liz's raps are horrible if you guys
heard of rats mm-hmm I finally listened
yet Megan the stallion that's what is
for kids I think I be quarantined with
her you guys like our DB oh yeah oh yeah
how'd she wipe her ass with those
[ __ ] nail I don't know about music
she's not where I'm from she wouldn't
try yeah how is she even scooper but
she's in Louisiana baby [ __ ] it now bro
dude wiping your ass is for the elite
bro scooping your butt is where it's at
so that's where the phrase got daddy
this is the last one that and we keep
talking but we're at an hour this is on
Stacy she's got three years worth of
toilet paper and she's strapped with
lice off this is sent in by Nathan three
years worth of toys that might be
illegal in the future like you know what
like it might be illegal to wipe her ass
more than three times pretty soon man
that might be a good point
nobody was wiping their ass and just
some [ __ ] figured out a way to make
a dollar now
y'all gotta wipe our asses man look at
that start George Washington what's
wrong with a dirty hole bro and didn't
even give a [ __ ] hit wooden teeth
there's no way you're wiping your butt
oh yeah it was good enough for our
founding fathers why did we go wipe our
asses 1857 yeah dude George Washington
never wiped his ass and guess what
George Washington never knew about
dinosaurs either oh [ __ ] how the [ __ ] do
you have wooden teeth like how does that
work I would look do they have that [ __ ]
in my George Washington's wooden teeth
like in some Museum
I don't like dude that would be huge
right that may be [ __ ] maybe they
agree wooden teeth I agree unless like
wouldn't go to me that oak like what
kind of dude it's gotta be like the
heart like the heart is [ __ ] wood are
they staying it yeah how does that work
teak maybe people just make [ __ ] up
I don't know sort of I don't know if I
buy that especially now history books
now could you imagine being in school
now and they're teaching history you
spiked apple tree crazy there's no
history class there couldn't be
dude history class do the class high
schools a joke yes all that [ __ ] in
those history books [ __ ] joke the
Mayflower one cat slavery yeah well we
spent a month on it did you get it yeah
February was slavery no no like we
didn't know if it even happened we did a
whole chapter on if it happened or not
now master Rick coops regular it was
this late that did did were slaves only
for the wealthy or just regular people
just have slaves to regular people
didn't have slaves no like 30 people had
slaves dude and they had a lot of them
it's just like it is now
yeah Mexicans are the new slaves well
Mexicans I don't I don't think the same
thing they figure it out they go dude we
don't have to [ __ ] house and feed
them how about we pay them like [ __ ]
five cents a day and let them find their
own [ __ ] place yeah [ __ ] they
probably it's just with slavery never
went away it's just there freelancing
now just drop private contract labor in
Libya all it is they goes dude you guys
are housing them and feeding them oh my
god yeah [ __ ] that
it's three them and then retire them and
let them buy the home food yeah yeah at
least a it's a same thing it's probably
better this
like that old way of slavery they'd have
said don't do sometimes yeah a lot the
hot one a lot of mixed baby the
abolishment of slavery was probably just
that reforming of slavery that's
probably what it really was Nazis didn't
never got the Nazis were never defeated
they just rebranded they just came to
the United States but yeah a lot of
people didn't have slays man most people
didn't is that true because it sounds
like everybody it was just wealthy
people right yeah people that could
afford to do it like you can't show up
with two dollars and get a slave man
you'd have like 13 not $1,300 you just
leave all 600 hours then you gotta feed
them to eat place for him to live you
came back I only get a say for $40 and
have him just sleep in my bed with me
you got like that was like slaving on a
budget house use a group yeah they
didn't have that so you can they were
basically fighting like like that's who
knows like exactly how it went down
because for sure black people were
slaves for sure but I want to know what
percentage of white people had slaves
like was it 2% was it 15% well 80% we
got I'm looking at something right now
that says 1.3 percent this is from this
is a Snopes article so take it was like
Oprah would have them no no it is 1% but
here's the rule at the time only white
men could buy an own slave so if you had
a family
you had slaves but you didn't
technically own it it was the guys who
owned it so the numbers are much smaller
and you still had racism though like you
still other people even though they wore
didn't have slaves they could still be
racist that was free yeah racism was
free back then and Marilyn was popping
off 12% oh definitely man large assault
20 what 12% of people had owned slaves
that's a lot Marilyn what's this hippie
says 49% 49% of white people owned
slaves 46 South Carolina Georgia 37 yeah
that's a lot that's a lot yeah but
that's just also a gas bro that's you
know well you think that was why people
did want it slaves but
they just couldn't afford him oh yeah
Christmas dude I've had dreams BER where
I am a you know that show um Undercover
Boss yeah where I go back in time I'm an
undercover boss I'm a slave and I'm like
seeing who's like being like a cool
slave and who's not you know were you in
blackface the whole time
I couldn't tell if I was black there
wasn't any mirrors or anything but
people treating me like I was a slave
like oh yeah this is a new guy you know
dream yeah weird wig right huh you had a
recurring dream that you were slave now
I like was my name back in like the
flower but in the 1600s or something
yeah I can't tell there's no calendar
there anything in the dream uh so I'm
guess I'm like probably fifteen hundred
or something sixteen hundred's Wow it
keeps popping back up yeah I've had it
probably about 15 times and it's like um
you know there and I'm seeing like oh
who's being sneaky and who's not you
know like who's planning on work and
who's planning on sneaking off yeah
undercover slow yeah cuz I'm the
Undercover Boss but I'm a slave so I'm
it's you not you know dirt yeah yeah but
not actually but it's kind of crazy it's
like a secret shopper kind of like well
we did it boys we did we saw it we did
it we solved Corona we did I think it's
over I think people have the information
now that's all we can do oh this is this
most social thing I'll probably do for
the next two or three days the gyms are
all closed what are you guys doing a
with a lot of tents planets closed they
have most of them some are still open in
certain counties where they didn't you
know they have an enforced lock do you
think they're gonna charge rent even
though their clothes oh yeah I'm losing
tens of thousands of dollars man I lost
some Bobby Jonica everybody is my
Bitcoin crashed it should have granted
that's the new slavery is anybody who's
bought Bitcoin Bitcoin us like everyone
else big coin just went to [ __ ] people
are supposed to keep in they've panicked
and they sold it
are there speakeasies out where people
are still training or you know what I'm
saying are there places where people are
moving around underground underground I
don't know how often do you use JIT -
never never what belt did you get uh
last time I got a belt was brown yeah
three stripes on my brown belt one one
strike so is what that black a black
belt jiu-jitsu I did I got I got stripes
and then I started fighting so I stopped
doing like Jitsu remember too late get
that black belt no yeah it's nice to say
you know I'm all Easton yeah yeah I'm
all Eastern was the one who gave my well
I'm all gave me my purple and then
Henner and here on give me my brown and
I got striped under here on tenor or go
train with the inner hair and getting to
my back yeah but I'm all asked me to
come back and was gonna give me my black
but I just I've been busy with other
things you said come back I'll give you
your black well to train for it at the
time I was training yeah I'll cheer you
on bro thanks dude
come with me yeah you know getting some
martial arts to me to get it now but
trying to do some yoga with me dude it's
the best really is he Jewish fighting
yeah dude dirty Jew fighting I love they
go for eyes and groin yeah it's just
it's just cheating win I'm all about
that what's it in between Krav Maga and
Brazilian jiu-jitsu how dare you
Brazilian jiu-jitsu you can actually
spar a hundred percent against each
other because there's no strikes it's a
sport gouging it's a sport so you get
really really good at controlling
another man's blotchy
but Krav Maga it's all about like ball
strikes I go judge the blind is it
really yeah so you really can't marshal
it's it's effective nothing's more
effective than a [ __ ] eye gouge my
god just number one I'm all about that
if you just focus on that
you know just anybody tackles you or
anything just focus on getting a thumb
and their eye on the fights over that's
the best [ __ ] right but you don't really
need a [ __ ] train that much for eye
gouges right know what I mean you got
the technique down yeah I can't even see
that great I'll fake like I got a gouge
and then come back with a counter attack
that's smart playing possum probably the
problem with focusing in on eye gouging
is it works so well it blinds
[ __ ] relax they can come back
and Sue you so be careful with that [ __ ]
be careful with that I got well if
that's the only thing you do do but it
will save your life it will save your
life for sure oh you got that I get them
you just get one eye all you need is one
you don't need to just tap it tap the
eye ball shot ball shots are great is
just that delay they got like 10 seconds
to [ __ ] the balls and run dude and by
the time they catch you both the pain
sets in come in man well thank you for
having is the first time we've ever had
celebrity guests on King in the sting
yeah culture corner uh but it's yeah
this is awesome man it's really cool
especially to talk about the virus and
see what's what's going on have you
heard what Ron Paul said that's what I
believe I'm behind Ron Paul yeah this is
all about trying to control stuff and
get Trump out of office you can catch
them on a tinfoil hat podcast and Bravo
this is Sam Tripoli thank you boys yes
you guys so much and thanks coming in
yeah Jen thank you for being here safe
yep
the few the proud the gang